[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
GARY GENSLER: So we've
got a lot to cover,
but I'm going to start with
a little background about
the internet and the payment
riddle; something about money,
which is at the core, really,
of all classes on finance but we
usually take for
granted; and then Satoshi
Nakamoto's innovation--
who was Satoshi Nakamoto,
what is that innovation; a
bit about crypto markets;
the blockchain
technology use cases--
and then the core
really is, how to think
about viability of
those use cases;
a little touch on central
bank digital currencies;
and ground truths.
So, a lot to cover.
If we don't get
through it all, we
will talk about
this again when we
talk about payments in class 6.
In terms of some
of the readings,
I shared with you two write-ups
that were done for a class
that Neha Narula and I
teach, an online class
called Cryptocurrency, which
is available through MIT.
And those two write-ups,
the "Economics of Money
and Technology"--
I'm sorry, and the
"Responses of Big Finance"
sort of give you some
of the challenges
and how to think through
these technologies.
Also, the Bank of
International Settlement
did a review just
earlier in 2020
about the central
bank digital currency
space, because so much
is going on there.
And particularly after Facebook
announced their Libra project
in June of 2019, many central
banks took note and said, wait,
maybe there's
something going on here
that we too need to do more.
Now, before Facebook
Libra, there
were many projects the bank--
one of the world's
largest central banks,
the Riksbank in
Sweden, was already
looking at an e-krona project.
There were other projects.
But all of a sudden, that
Facebook Libra project kicked
into high gear central
bankers around the globe,
and particularly
China's look and review
and announcements around the
Digital Currency Electronic
Payments Project also
got kicked into gear.
So regardless of
where you come out,
whether blockchain technology,
cryptocurrencies, are getting
rolled into the stack, rolled
into the technology stack
of big finance.
What we can say as of 2020,
what's really the case,
is that cryptocurrencies
and blockchain technology
have at least been a
catalyst for change,
an important catalyst for
change pushing upon big finance,
pushing upon central
banks to reconsider
how they do payments, how
they do the basics of money.
And I laid out a few questions.
Again, Romain will
look for some hands.
We're going to keep this a
little shorter than we usually
do, just because we have
so much to cover, but,
how does Bitcoin fit into
the history of money?
What are the strategic and
tactical considerations
assessing viability
and value propositions?
And how are these
central banks thinking
about what they're doing?
And Romain, if we can just
see if we could get one or two
people in kind of each of
these three questions--
and these are the
essential questions
I'm going to try to cover
in the next hour or so.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Sounds good.
Who would like to
get us started?
I'm watching for
your blue hands.
GARY GENSLER: Quiet day today.
AUDIENCE: If you wish, Gary,
I'm also happy to cold call.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
Well, I'm going to start.
I'm going to kind of just go.
But I hoped that
everyone would come in.
I start with this scene--
and I don't know anyone who
wants to raise a blue hand
and tell me what movie
this is from and the era.
But this is the opening scene
of a movie from the mid 1990s,
The Net, 1995, Sandra Bullock.
Now, I start with this, because
Pizza Net was actually real.
Now, this cyber security
sort of spy thriller
with Sandra Bullock sort of
cracking through the computer
network--
remember, let's place this.
Mid 1990s.
It was only the early 1990s
that Tim Berners-Lee, associated
with MIT, actually came
up with the protocols that
connects the world wide web.
The internet had been
around for some time,
coming out of DARPA and
the Department of Defense
in the US and
academic institutions.
But by the early
'90s, it was actually
something that those
of us in the public
could use beyond universities,
beyond the defense
establishment and the like.
But what hadn't
been solved, what
hadn't been solved
by 1995, was how
to move money on the internet.
And Pizza Hut founded something
called Pizza Net, which
is thought to be the
first commercial use where
you could actually
order something online--
just 25 years ago--
order something
online through Pizza Net.
There was only sort
of one problem.
You ordered the
pizza, and guess what?
You couldn't pay online.
Nobody had figured
out how to pay online.
You had to have the pizza
delivery at your door,
and you paid.
So just think.
It's in the middle of
the corona lockdown,
we're sheltering at home.
And if it weren't for these
inventions of 25 years ago
we're about to discuss, you
would be paying for that pizza
at the door when the
delivery truck arrived,
or for your groceries, or
for any other household
goods that you have.
So this riddle, what I call the
payments riddle, what others
call the payments
riddle, was at the core
of this new technology,
the internet.
Now, the internet has been fully
adopted into the technology
stack of finance by now.
But in the mid 1990s, it
was, in essence, fintech.
But the question is how to
move value on the internet,
to do it securely, efficiently,
and really importantly,
similar to the packets of
data that move on the internet
as packets of data,
and thus peer-to-peer.
So the internet doesn't
really have central control.
All the data that we're
live streaming right now
between and amongst us, between
78 participants on this Zoom
meeting right now,
is through packets
of data that's not through
one central control,
even though we think, well, Zoom
might be controlling all this.
But the challenge really
was, how could you
prohibit double spending?
How could you send a packet
of data to one person
and ensure that
that packet of data
wasn't also sent to another,
in essence, double spending?
Having some data
like an email that we
might send to two people--
they were both reading
the same email,
they don't know that each
are reading the same email.
So that was this
payments riddle--
secure, efficient
packets of data,
but avoiding double spending.
Lots of challenges,
lots of attempts.
And there were
dozens of attempts.
Somebody even went to
go in to get patents
and started businesses,
raised money.
Some of them through the
earlier days of venture capital
were backed like
CyberCash and DigiCash,
and E-gold, B-Money,
all of these failed.
All of them, and
dozens more beyond what
I list here in the 1990s,
and the hurdles were, well,
of course the same hurdles
that any startup would
have around merchant adoption--
would the stores
actually adopt it--
but this issue of
double spending.
And the only sort of
solution to double spending
was using centralization.
There was one central computer,
one central controller,
to avoid the double spending.
Or the other side of it,
how did you form consensus?
If you didn't have a
central controller,
how to form consensus on
the say of who had the money
and who didn't have the money.
So this sort of central
payments riddle,
a big issue in the
1990s, attracted
the interest of a
cryptography group
called the cypherpunk community.
I kid you not, it's called
cypherpunk community.
It was an email list that
had started in the late 1980s
and had gone on for some time.
And so there were early
digital solutions that
were a little bit different.
And some of the cryptography
that was brought to it
was not brought from the
cypherpunk community,
it was brought to bear from
great cryptographers, some
of them at MIT, some
elsewhere, that came together
by 1996 with a solution.
It's this updated today the
same solution we use now--
secure socket layer and
transport layer security.
These two protocols, on hop
of Tim Berners-Lee protocols
about the world wide web from
four or five years earlier.
These are the main protocols--
there are many others
that were added.
But these are the main
protocols that allowed
us to secure the internet.
It's how we do it right now--
a transfer of data
that's secured
by the use of cryptography.
And what did that lead to?
That led to a lot
of things where
we could accept Visas and
MasterCard, American Express,
by the mid 1990s.
Amazon, eBay were
both formed in 1995.
It's a founder's dream
to get formed right when
a technology is transitioning.
If Amazon, if Jeff Bezos
had been formed in 1992,
would it still have
been around by 1996
when the secure socket
layer and the cryptography
was there for him to get going?
If Jeff Bezos had decided
to form it in 1998 or '99,
it might have been too late.
Now, there's a lot
of things that Amazon
got right and Visa's got right.
But I'm saying timing was
one that was remarkable.
PayPal came along in 1998.
And interestingly, the
first mobile payments
was actually Ericsson teaming
up with Telenor in 1999.
Now, that product is
not around today--
or maybe somebody will
correct me and say
there's still a little bit.
But one of the early
ones that really took off
was Alipay and then
M-Pesa in Kenya.
Now, All of this still
left the payments riddle.
That payments riddle
was still there
to some in that
cypherpunk community.
Now, the internet could
get commercialized,
the internet could move on.
We had this way
through cryptography
to secure payments.
But there was still
this question.
And it goes to the
heart of, what is money?
And so I'm going to turn a
little bit to chat about money,
but just see if Romain
has any questions so far.
AUDIENCE: Nobody at the moment.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
So I'd like to go back in time.
I'd like to go back 2,300, 2,400
years in talking about money.
It's not the first time
money was discussed,
because money was
really an invention
of humankind thousands
of years before that.
But I'd like to go back
to Plato and Aristotle.
Plato did not write
extensively on money.
But what he did
write is interesting.
It's that money is
a symbol devised
for the purpose of exchanges.
To think, you and I were
going to exchange something--
at the time, maybe it
was a goat for wheat,
maybe I needed the goat today,
you needed the wheat tomorrow--
but we can use this
symbol, as Plato wrote,
as a purpose of that exchange.
And interestingly,
separately Plato wrote--
Plato wasn't in for using
gold and silver for money.
Now, this is
interesting in contrast
to Plato's student, Aristotle.
Now, Aristotle wrote
extensively about money.
It seemed like Aristotle wrote
extensively about many things,
but one of them was money.
And Aristotle wrote
that it solves
the problem of
commensurability--
the same sort of issue that
Plato was grappling with,
commensurability.
You need rice, you need
grains, I need goats.
How do we have some
commensurability between that?
Or the second point here,
money is a guarantee
that we have what we
want in the future.
So this is sort of a
time commensurability.
I need something today, you
need something tomorrow.
So these two forms of marrying
up needs and wants and values--
Aristotle talked also
as a philosopher about,
what is values?
And then talked about
four absolute values.
Now, I hate to disagree
with Aristotle.
But, you know, over
time, there are
many of Aristotle's
great writings that
have been challenged--
about the Earth and about
the solar system, about the
heavens, the skies, the bodies.
So why not say that maybe
Aristotle didn't quite
have it right about money?
He talked about durability,
portability, divisibility.
I still sort of agree.
And most monetary economists
would agree on that.
It's this fourth point--
did it have intrinsic value?
I find myself more
associated with Plato, who
had said it was just a symbol.
It's but a symbol.
And so today when we
think about money,
we often think of six
key characteristics.
Is it durable,
portable, divisible?
These were--
Aristotle seemed to--
2,300 years later people
still tend to agree.
But rather than intrinsic value,
that it's uniform, acceptable,
and stable we'll talk
a little bit more
about that when we get to the
economics of cryptocurrencies.
But remember, instead
of intrinsic value,
that it's uniform; that it's
the same unit of account
within some local
or national economy;
that others accept it, because
if others don't accept it,
how can I know that that which I
take today I can use tomorrow?;
and then its value is stable.
And we think over the
last 300-plus years
about institutions
that help ensure
that currency value is stable,
we call them central banks.
So instead of an
intrinsic value, that we
humans create some form of
acceptability, uniformity,
and stability.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: None so far, but I'll
give our students a few seconds
to raise their hand
if they want to.
Yes, we have a
question from Hassan.
GARY GENSLER: Please, Hassan.
AUDIENCE: Hello, professor.
Yeah, my question
is, when you said
that people could exchange
things for other things
as a mean.
So I mean, how could
the cryptocurrency
survive if there is no
intrinsic value in it
and it's so volatile?
And when you said that
central banks make
sure that these currencies
are stable, it's because--
like for instance, in my
country the central bank
has to have gold
and other currencies
to support our currency,
our local currency.
So I'm just baffled to see like
someone speak about, well, you
know what, it's only a symbol.
OK, I know that it
is a symbol, but it
has to have some value in it.
Otherwise, the other
party would not
accept it as a means of
exchange, if that makes sense.
GARY GENSLER: So Hassan
is associating himself
more with Aristotle
than Plato, and I
find myself more associated
with Plato than Aristotle.
So this is a worthy
debate that's
gone on for well over a
couple of thousand years.
But when I say that it
doesn't have intrinsic value,
and it's more about uniformity,
acceptability, instability,
think about--
I'll take the US dollar.
I don't know-- what
you're country?
AUDIENCE: I'm from Bahrain.
GARY GENSLER: So
I'm not as familiar
with your central bank.
But let's take the US
dollar instead of Bahraini.
If you walk into
the Federal Reserve,
the US Federal Reserve, and
you have $100 bill-- you know,
paper currency, $100--
what will they give you?
I mean, other than that
they would probably send you
on your way and the
security guard would say,
we're in this
coronavirus period,
nobody's allowed
in the building.
But what would they
do if you showed up
at the New York Federal
Reserve or the Richmond Federal
Reserve, and you said, I
want something for this $100?
AUDIENCE: I suppose
that a few years ago
that they would give you like
gold, if that makes sense.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
So we got rid of that in 1933.
So "a few years ago" would
be like at the beginning
of the Great Depression under
President Roosevelt. What
would they give you in 2020?
AUDIENCE: They would give me,
I think, the government's--
that the government
basically would support
this piece of paper, I assume.
GARY GENSLER: So you're
getting at the government which
sort of insure, through
its means and methods,
that it's acceptable
by other citizens,
and it's acceptable
by the government.
How do they do that?
They say, well, we'll
take it for US taxes.
We'll take it for
Bahranian taxes.
And in most economies,
the governments
are anywhere from
a quarter to a half
of the economy in some
way, so they will accept it
for a government.
They'll ensure that other
people accept it through what's
called legal tender laws.
Through the coercive power
of the state, they will say,
others must accept it.
And this is not a new thing.
Genghis Khan was
doing this in China,
and it was pretty coercive.
It was kind of [CLICKS TONGUE]
the coercive power
of the state, you must
accept the official currency.
So acceptability can be
accepted by the government.
It could be
acceptability that others
must accept it for all
debts, public and private.
And they can work on stability
and form central banks
to ensure that-- now, what
does it mean by stability?
It means addressing the
official sector to the supply
and pricing of money.
Supply and pricing--
the supply we
talk about the monetary
supply, the pricing
is through interest rates.
But can you go into
the US Central Bank,
can you go into Bahrain
and actually get gold?
No.
You can go in and
get a $100 bill,
and they might
give you five 20's.
If you really want,
they'll give you 100 1's.
But you still have
just a physical piece
of paper or a digital
representation
that I would contend--
I'm sort of with Plato--
it's just a symbol.
It's a symbol that
our society, no matter
whether it's small or
big, has come together.
And it represents
a store of value.
It represents a
means of exchange.
But it frankly doesn't have
intrinsic value the way
Aristotle talked about it.
It has only value because we
humans place a value on it.
But Hassan, are you on
still on the other side?
You feel gold has
intrinsic value.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
I think because
it's a scarce metal.
And I know that prices
could go up and down,
but still I know that
I could sell it one day
and get money or get--
GARY GENSLER: So gold is
what we now call an element.
It's on the periodic table.
It's got great attributes
because it's scarce.
It takes a lot of
human resources
to get it out of the ground.
The other thing about gold,
it's divisible, it's portable,
it's uniform.
It doesn't oxidize, so it's
a really good base sort
of element in that way as well.
And now we have, give
or take, 10,000 years
of acceptability, that it's
a human shared narrative.
Some of it not good,
some of it about war,
and slavery, and all sorts of
challenges in human history.
But gold, and to a
lesser extent silver,
were very acceptable and stable.
But think about
this for a moment.
All the world's gold
that's ever been mined,
if you take all of
that gold, it can fit
in four Olympic-sized pools.
Four Olympic-sized pools,
you. could put all that gold
into one space.
Now, it's spread
around the world
in jewelry and secure vaults.
But it's only four
Olympic-sized pools.
I would kind of contend
that's just a symbol.
Again, it has some kind of
features that make it durable,
and it's got 10,000
years of human narrative
and acceptability.
And I can assure
you that those who
are really in times of
trouble would probably
take a piece of gold--
if it was really in
times of war and despair,
take a piece of
gold over Bitcoin.
But on the other
hand, we're going
to get into what
Bitcoin is and how
it creates some digital
scarce store of value.
So Hassan, we could keep
going with a lively debate,
but I hope that helps at least
frame the sides of this thing.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I just
have one thing to say.
Now, I mean, if the US
for some reason collapsed,
what would happen to the
whole monetary system?
I mean, it's very dangerous,
if that makes sense.
Because--
GARY GENSLER: You're asking
what happens if a nation's
currency collapses.
And we have history of that.
We don't have
recent history when
a world's dominant
currency collapses,
but we've certainly a
history of many countries'
currencies collapsing.
In fact, right now Venezuela's
currency basically collapses.
And what happens in countries
that where the currencies enter
hyperinflation and
start to collapse,
you start to see communities
reach out to another symbol,
some other symbol that is
acceptable and has stability.
It might be in the common
time, in the current time,
that those people will
reach out to the US dollar.
And your question is, what
if the dollar collapses?
But in monetary history
serves that usually
that when a currency goes
bad, people reach out
to the better currency.
And it could be a
neighboring country.
It could be a different
metal, like when
we had challenges between
different base metals,
or even earlier
times, when we had
money that looked a little
different than we currently
looked like.
Let me hold that about what
happens to the US dollar
for a moment and
just say, the role
of money, because
we will lose time,
and I want to get going
as to what cryptocurrency
and blockchain technology is.
So the role of money
is three things--
a medium of exchange,
as Plato and Aristotle
talked about; a store of
value, that Aristotle basically
said that I can hold it today
for something tomorrow-- that's
a store of value; and it also
then becomes a unit of account.
The US dollar is a unit
of account in the US,
the yen in Japan, the euro
in Europe, a unit of account.
These three roles of money.
And it's looked very
different over time.
Cowrie shells in Greece.
But today, I put here
an Alipay mobile wallet.
That's sort of what we use
dominantly around the world.
We talked a little bit
about fiat currency
when Hassan and I were
going back and forth.
A fiat currency is
a representation
of some central bank liability.
Central banks, an invention
of the late 17th century
both in England and
in Sweden, just about
the same decade in
the late 17th century,
was a check on the sovereign.
You see the king,
the king in England--
using that story for a moment--
the king was at yet
another war with France
and wanted to borrow money.
And when the king
wanted to borrow money,
going to the noble
lords, the noble lords
said, enough already,
king, and said, we
need some mechanism to control
how much you can borrow.
And how much you can
borrow is, in essence,
a representation of money.
And they set up the
Bank of England.
And in Sweden it was a
check also on the sovereign
for a little bit different
political reasons
than a war with France.
And there we had the initial
sort of central banks.
Here in the US we
went about it--
Alexander Hamilton thought
we should have something.
That was during the 1790s.
By the 1830s,
Andrew Jackson said,
enough with this sort
of centralized banking.
And then we went for nearly
80 years-- about 75 years,
from the 1830s to the 19-teens--
with no central bank.
We had crisis after
crisis, and we formed one
during President
Wilson's time, one
of the great progressive
movements of the day and just
about a hundred years ago.
But fiat currencies are
representations of liabilities.
And Hassan would say,
well, but don't they
have something behind it?
What they have behind it
is the government's ability
to, of course, tax, the
government's ability
to be trusted to keep
its promises to keep
that currency stable.
But again, just like when
that English king was
at war with France, sometimes--
sometimes-- they
overprint the money.
Sometimes it gets out of control
and central banks lose control.
But it has very big network
effects that we talked about.
The acceptance for
taxes for legal tender,
it's accepted through
what Mundell would say
was an optimum currency area.
Now, we have 180 currencies
around the globe.
And some work well and
some don't work so well,
like Venezuela right now.
And so in the midst
of all of that,
the question is, and
this a little humorous,
is, what's money's future?
Is it digital currencies?
Or is it like in kind of
the fun movie Star Wars,
is it these types of things,
credit chips and the like?
Now, I would say if
you're a Star Trek
fan, in Star Trek Gene
Roddenberry didn't
have any currency.
If you go through
all the original Star
Treks and everything, they
actually didn't have any money.
That was Gene
Roddenberry's future.
So he sort of dispensed with
all this Plato and Aristotle--
Let's now sort of go a
little bit more serious
and then talk about
Satoshi Nakamoto.
But Romain, any questions?
AUDIENCE: None so far.
Let's give it a few seconds.
No, I think we're good to go.
GARY GENSLER: So
with that foundation,
let's go back to
the payments riddle.
So we get through the 1990s.
The internet is taking off, we
figure out how to secure it,
and the credit card companies
find a way to move money.
Some startups happen.
PayPal and the like
start up in this area,
the fintech of the late 1990s.
Mobile payments
start by the noughts.
We already have Alipay
and M-Pesa in Africa.
But this payment
riddle is still there.
And that cypherpunk mailing
list is still there.
And on Halloween night in
2008, an eight-page paper
is written and is put up on
the internet on this cypherpunk
punk mailing list-- there
might only be a couple people.
"I've been working on a new
electronic cash system."
Peer-to-peer, no trusted third
party, no central authority.
And what Satoshi Nakamoto wrote
in that eight-page paper, what
Nakamoto-san wrote was
Bitcoin white paper.
Had never used the word
"blockchain technology."
We've come to call it
blockchain technology.
So, what is the
blockchain technology?
fundamentally, it's a
shared accounting system--
a shared accounting system
or a shared database system.
So Satoshi Nakamoto had
timestamped ledgers.
And a timestamped ledger with
cryptography to secure it
was not new.
A timestamped ledger-- my
little illustration here,
Neha Narula and I use this,
so I want to give her credit
as well--
represents blocks of data.
Blocks of data, and between
these blocks of data
a cryptographic hash function.
And a cryptographic
hash function
we use every day
of our lives, just
we don't know we're using
it, somewhere on the internet
to commit to data.
This technology, this idea
of taking a block of data
and adding another
block of data and having
a hash function in
between, was an innovation
of the late 1980s.
Two Bell Labs scientists,
Haber and Stornetta,
wrote a paper about it,
even started a company
to notarize legal
documents by 1995,
a little startup called Surety.
That existed.
That existed, but what
Nakamoto-san figured out
was how to have
multiple parties.
Nakamoto-san solved
the consensus riddle,
or what some people call
Byzantine general's problem.
The problem is, what if I don't
know the other people keeping
a ledger?
Again, the Byzantine
general's problem was not new.
It wasn't even about money.
The Byzantine general's
problem had been written
about in the early 1980s.
It was a computer
systems problem.
If you tie various computers
together, what if one of them
fails?
Or even in an airplane, what
if one of the engines fails?
It's the question
of fault tolerance.
But what Satoshi Nakamoto
did was solved it
through something
called proof of work.
And we don't have the time
to go through that, but what
this provided together was
a decentralized, auditable
database.
Now, in the case of
Bitcoin 10,000 computers
around the globe maintain
this auditable database.
And this audible
database builds a block
of data on top of a block of
data on top of a block of data,
but its shared accounting
system maintains it.
There was one other thing that
went on in this period time.
In the late 1990s, a
computer scientist Nick Szabo
wrote a paper and coined the
phrase "smart contracts."
Again, not an original idea.
But what Nick Szabo
said, what if we
could take a set of promises,
put them in digital form,
and then the parties can
perform against them?
In essence, what if we
automate in computer
code the movement
of a property right?
Now, I grew up in
Baltimore, Maryland.
My dad had a vending
machine business.
You know, cigarette machines
and candy machines and the like.
A vending machine
is a smart contract.
It's a conditional movement
of property rights.
It's a pack of gum if you put
some money in the machine.
So you can think
of a smart contract
as digitizing, basically,
a vending machine.
They're not necessarily
smart, they're not necessarily
legal contracts.
So I'd be cautious about that.
But these two concepts came
together-- smart contracts,
meaning, can I digitize the
movement of a property right?
And then this accounting
system of a shared ledger,
that multiple parties
can share a ledger
with no central controller.
That's kind of the
conceptual frame where
I want to pause for
a second, Romain,
and take questions
on what I usually
cover in a lot more time
than the few minutes
that I just did.
AUDIENCE: Any questions
from the students?
GARY GENSLER: This
must be because we just
went through holiday time and
we had our Zoom Easters and Zoom
seders.
AUDIENCE: There are
no hands raised now.
Ah, we do have one
question from Celi.
GARY GENSLER: Please.
AUDIENCE: So I was
just wondering,
can you explain a
little more the issues
of the decentralized
audible database?
You mentioned it very briefly
that it first came out
and how [INAUDIBLE] were solved.
But can you-- just to understand
what issues they are solving.
Can you kind of
explain a little?
GARY GENSLER: So if I
understand the question,
what Nakamoto-san
was trying to solve
was what has been come to
called double spending.
Can you in a digital way move
a representation of value,
in a digital way move
that, without having
a central authority?
We move digitally representation
of values every day.
When you go online and buy
something-- you go to Expedia,
you go to Amazon,
you go to Alibaba--
we move digitally
representation of values.
We no longer have much of
our economy on physical cash.
But we always have some
central authority-- a bank,
a payments company that
we'll talk about in class 6--
some central
authority controlling
that to ensure that
you actually have
that value, to
authenticate and authorize
the movement of that money.
So what Satoshi
Nakamoto was solving
for is, what if there
was no central authority?
And it was a shared
database or ledger,
or what I call a shared
accounting system.
That would be the core thing.
This kind of riddle
from the 1990s,
we send packets of data
around the internet
with this out-of-central
authority,
maybe you could do that.
And I don't think it's
a surprise this happened
in the middle of a
financial crisis, Halloween
financial crisis,
when trust in central
authorities was quite low,
and especially trust in
Wall Street and banking,
and banks in Europe
was quite low.
This burst of innovation
came at that time.
I hope that helps.
And I think as we're going
to chat through today
and in other
classes, the question
is, are there
other applications?
See, this goes to
the heart of finance.
It goes to the heart
of the plumbing.
Satoshi Nakamoto's innovation
still survives 12 years later.
In this adversarial sort
of off-the-grid way,
Bitcoins still survives
12 years later.
But are there other
applications in finance,
where a shared database system,
a shared accounting system
is the best way to go?
And we've had
inventions like this,
infrastructure technologies that
have radically changed finance.
And one of them from
several hundred years ago
was the joint stock company.
When I talk about
a technology stack,
one from several
centuries ago was,
can we have a shared
ownership of a company?
And when that was
sort of invented,
I guess some people would have
said, what do we need that for?
This, instead of a shared
company, is a shared database.
And so that's the debate.
Is it really needed?
Will it be useful in the future?
It has led to a crypto
market, about $200 billion
as of yesterday, 2/3 of which
is Bitcoin, highly volatile.
Hassan would say, but
what's the intrinsic value?
It is a digital
scarce store of value.
And it only has value because
somebody else will move it.
When Bitcoin was
rolled out in 2009,
nobody saw that it had value.
It was just a kind of
interesting project.
But by 2010, one person
who was in the community
said, let's see if I could
get anybody to give me
something commercially.
And it was actually pizza.
It wasn't Pizza Net,
the Sandra Bullock
movie we started with in 1995.
But 15 years later in 2010, a
crypto enthusiast in Florida
put out-- on an email asked,
I will give you 10,000 bitcoin
if you send me two pizzas.
Two pizzas, 1,000
bitcoin in May of 2010.
It took about a week
before anybody responded.
But two pizzas showed
up at his door,
and sure enough this crypto
enthusiast in Florida
sent the 10,000 bitcoin.
Now, at the time, there
wasn't a crypto market.
At the time, it was
thought that the two
pizzas were worth about $42 that
he had paid 10,000 bitcoin for.
That 10,000 bitcoin today would
be valued at about $65 million.
So 10 years later,
you kind of go, well,
that was kind of an
interesting time to do that.
It's led to different sectors.
There's thousands
of these coins.
The payment or store
of value tokens
are the dominant, about
3/4 of the market.
Some of you may have
heard of Ethereum.
But platform tokens were--
Vitalik Buterin rolled out
this thing called Ethereum.
And Ethereum is conceptually
a worldwide shared computer.
It has many attributes
of operating system.
I wouldn't compare
it and contrasted
with iOS and Android, but it
does have attributes similar
to a worldwide platform
layer operating system,
upon which distributed
applications or dApps can
be put on top.
So this is this ecosystem.
There's a few dozen payment
or store value tokens.
There's dozens of
platform tokens.
There's 1,000 to 2,000
applications placed on top.
The conceptual framework
in these applications
is they're decentralized.
Will anybody use them--
different questions
along the way.
So, what has this led to?
It's led to blockchain use cases
around speculative investing.
Crowdfunding through
initial coin offerings--
from 2017 to 2019,
nearly $30 billion
was raised by basically
selling a token
before you had a business.
You might have a
good idea, you might
have the legitimate players, and
you raised money off of this.
You weren't selling equity,
you were not selling debt,
you were selling a
token that could be used
on some site in the future.
Now, those tokens
have largely been--
in 2020 this is--
those tokens are largely
for crypto exchanges,
for gaming, for
gambling, for something
called decentralized
finance, and file sharing.
Now, there's something
that's consistent
about the first three--
crypto exchanges, gaming,
and gambling.
Some of the users of these
gaming/gambling exchange sites
want a sort of a basis
of staying off the grid.
They want censorship resistance.
So the thing about
cryptocurrencies,
the good and the bad sometimes,
is the official sector,
though they can track some of
it, they can't track all of it.
That it's some way sometimes
to stay off the grid.
I'm not advising this.
I'm just saying the economics
of it, some of that,
is about censorship-resistant.
All of the other uses has been
around blockchain technology.
And the uses really
are potential uses.
They haven't taken off.
Can we use it in
payment systems?
Can we use it in trade finance?
Can we use it in clearing
settling and processing?
And there are
hundreds of projects
that have been in proof of
concept or pilot stages, none
that have truly broken out yet.
And this is why I say it hasn't
come into the technology stack.
You can, by the way,
get your MIT diploma
on blockchain technology.
I'm saying that if you
do, you can decide also
to get it in paper form.
I thought-- Romain, actually we
had a poll just to see how many
people--
there's a poll on use of
cryptocurrency or something,
the first of those two polls.
If folks don't mind just
giving a little flavor for,
have you ever owned
crypto, and so forth.
So it looks like a third have
owned Bitcoin or Ethereum
or AUT Coins.
And we have-- does
Bitcoin exhibit
the three roles of money?
A little over half yes, and
a little less than a half no.
I'm going to ask if somebody--
one person on the yes side, one
person on the no
side-- just points
to articulate why
it does not exhibit
the three roles of money--
the store of value,
medium of exchange,
unit of account.
And for this Romain,
we'll cold call.
So if somebody wants to take
the lead on either side.
AUDIENCE: Any volunteers?
Camilo.
GARY GENSLER: And
if you can declare
which side you're on so somebody
can volunteer on the other side
as well.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
am on the no side.
I mean, I--
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So just for a moment, so
if somebody on the optimist
positive side please volunteer.
But Camilo.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, no.
I mean, I think that still
as a medium of exchange,
Bitcoin and the rest
of the cryptocurrencies
are really limited.
If I want to go to, I
don't know, the public
and buy something with
Bitcoin, it would be so hard.
I'll have to find an
app that translates
my Bitcoin to real money
and then try to pay.
And there is also a questionable
thing about the store of value.
You know, Bitcoin at least-- and
Ethereum I think is also true--
had been fluctuating
so much that you never
know how much value are you're
getting for a bitcoin day
to day.
So I think there is still a
long way before fulfilling
the essentials of money.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So I think Camilo is saying,
I can't go to Publix,
not a medium of exchange
where I want to go.
And it's kind of this
volatile store of value.
And you didn't address
a unit of account.
But let's see if
there's somebody
on the other side who just
wants to kind of articulate
the other side of this.
AUDIENCE: We have Devin.
GARY GENSLER: Devin, please.
AUDIENCE: Oof.
I can give the counter,
at least in my opinion.
I don't think that the
idea of a store of value
and the medium exchange are
shortcomings of the currency.
I think they're shortcomings
of the market in which it
operates.
So you can use it
to exchange value.
If the infrastructure
isn't there,
that's not the
currencies fault, that's
sort of the market participants.
And then with the store of
value, it does store a value.
That value does
fluctuate, that's true.
But again, I think that's
because of the market it's in
and speculation going on
around these currencies.
GARY GENSLER: Camilo
do you want to--
you both are unmuted.
You can cross-- and Devin
can stay unmuted, too.
Any reply just for 30 seconds?
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
I just want to say that,
although it's true that
the value of the Bitcoin, it
fluctuates with the market,
the point is that if you want
a worldwide accepted medium
of exchange, it cannot
fluctuate as much as a Bitcoin.
Otherwise, the
financial system--
and even people who have savings
wouldn't have their savings
in Bitcoin.
I mean, you are not going
to put your funding,
your savings account
into Bitcoin,
because you might get
losses overnight, so.
GARY GENSLER: And [Devin.
AUDIENCE: I agree that
it does fluctuate.
I wouldn't put my savings in it.
I never have, I never will.
But I do think it
kind of comes down
to what is the exact definition
of the question you're
trying to answer.
Can you store value in it?
Yes.
Is the value going to
be the same tomorrow?
Maybe not.
And that's something that
might stabilize over time as--
like, if it gets used more
for day-to-day interactions
like going to the
shop, and it's not
kind of speculation and
sort of hype around it,
then maybe we can kind
of converge to a point
where it does satisfy
everything fully.
GARY GENSLER: And this
debate that Devin and Camilo
are helping frame is debate
that's a worthy debate.
I will tell you that I'm
not a Bitcoin maximalist,
but I actually--
I'm probably a little
closer to Devin than Camilo
on this in terms of, it is a
digital scarce store of value.
Will it be worth something
10 years from now?
Maybe not, maybe not.
But it has survived
kind of in this swamp,
it's this uncertain sort
of world, for 12 years.
And it has some
value to some folks.
Hassan earlier would say, but
it doesn't have intrinsic value.
And I would say, well, it's
just a symbol in any regard.
It can be a medium of
exchange in certain places.
But it needs an infrastructure.
Camilo is absolutely right.
The state treasurer of Ohio
in late 2018 had announced--
a state controller, I
think it might have been,
in Ohio, an elected office--
that the state of Ohio would
accept Bitcoin for taxes.
Was it just for
political reasons
that this gentleman
announced it,
that he thought he was
associating himself
with a new innovation
in the economy?
But they needed
an infrastructure
to accept the Bitcoin.
They had to convert it for a
1% fee to US dollars for sure.
It's not much of
a unit of account.
But sometimes it becomes
a unit of account inside
of these other decentralized
apps inside the ICO space.
So it sort of probably exhibits
one out of the three mostly.
It's a speculative
store of value.
It can be a medium of exchange.
It can be a unit of account.
But it hasn't adopted this.
A number of years ago, the
Financial Stability Board,
a worldwide organization of
20-- the G20 finance ministers
and central bankers, decided
that they would no longer call
Bitcoin and others
cryptocurrencies,
and they'd call
them crypto assets.
So they were associating
more with Camilo's side.
They were saying,
we're not going
to give this the kind of
word to call it a currency.
And yet, the US
Department of Treasury
some seven years ago
had to address itself
to the question
of whether Bitcoin
and other similar digital assets
were currency under US Bank
Secrecy Act laws, against
money laundering and the like.
And for that purpose,
they said that Bitcoin
was a virtual currency.
So there's the US Department of
Treasury fitting it into a box.
Now, I dare say they
needed to somehow address
this public policy
issue as to whether it
was going to be regulated
under the Bank Secrecy Act.
So somehow they had
to call it a currency,
call it a virtual currency.
Another part of
the US Department
of Treasury about
the same time said
it was going to be treated
as property for tax purposes.
So inside the US
Treasury Department,
clearly for purposes
of trying to decide
how it's going to be taxed,
how it's going to be treated
for anti-money laundering
laws, one part of the Treasury
called a virtual
currency, another part
of the US Treasury called it
property rather than currency.
And that fit into that.
So I think I'll move
on a little bit.
But we can take down
the poll, I think.
Or do I do that?
You--
AUDIENCE: So every
person should be
able to close that
little polling window.
I do not have control over it.
GARY GENSLER: OK.
Then I need to do that here
for a second so that it closes.
OK.
So there's a lot of challenges
of this shared accounting
system.
Scalability,
performance-- you can
move about 7 or 10 transactions
on Bitcoin per second.
You can move 10 to 20
transactions a second
on Ethereum.
That's kind of not the shot
that we need to this system.
Our shared, centralized
equity-clearing system here
in the US, the Depository
Trust, DTCC, needs to move--
the Securities and Exchange
Commission sort of said,
you need to be able to move
about 100 million transactions
a day.
Well, guess what?
In the middle of one of the
most volatile time in February,
DTCC was moving 350
million transactions.
And when I say transactions, it
could be for a hundred shares,
it could be a thousand shares
or if the volumes in shares
was higher.
But I'm talking about how
many transactions were
moving through that system.
Blockchain technology
by and large
has a bunch of issues
still to sort through,
is the point, from public policy
issues, commercial use cases,
and the like.
And the question
is for the 2020,
as these scalability,
performance,
and efficiency issues,
as privacy and security,
as some of these
are worked through,
is a shared accounting system,
a shared ledger system something
that's going to take off?
And I go back to economic
work from the 1930s by Coase.
And i just sort of capture
it in a little slide here
the trade-offs of centralization
and decentralization,
and these as a cost curve.
But centralization
does lead to cost,
about a single point of
failure, about economic rents,
and about capture.
We all know that we
pay more for something
that's highly centralized.
If you want to build an app
on top of iOS or on top--
Apple's iOS or an app on
top of Google's Android,
you're going to pay a
fee, because they're
the two dominant
pipes if you need
to deal with certain
centralized financial systems,
there's more economic rents.
And in fact, the
financial sector in the US
takes about 7 and
1/2% of our economy.
That's double what
it took in the 1960s.
Now, it's a bigger economy,
it's a bigger financial sector.
But does it necessarily need to
take 7 and 1/2% of our economy?
So some would say,
those are some
of the costs of centralization.
And then there's also
cost of decentralization--
coordination, governance,
security, scalability.
Now, Coase was
writing in the 1930s
why do you bring together
certain attributes inside
of a firm.
It was about the
theory of the firm
and why some things
are inside a firm.
And it was the cost
of information,
the cost of coordination, that
you bring some things inside,
some things are left out.
The question is, will this
change this balance somehow?
Vitalik Buterin talked
about a trilemma
and said it's hard to
get all three of these,
to get security,
decentralization,
and scalability.
So Buterin is the innovator,
at 19, of the Ethereum network.
He's now 25, maybe.
But Vitalik Buterin
said, look, you
can get decentralization like
in Bitcoin and secure it.
It's reasonably secure,
but it's not scalable.
You maybe can get
towards scalability,
but you're probably
going to tend
towards more centralization.
Now, one of MIT's award-winning
computer scientists,
Silvio Micali, says,
no, he disagrees.
He says you can
actually solve for this.
Silvio won the Turing Award.
He's sort of the father--
considered the
father of something
called zero-knowledge
proofs, and said, no, you
can solve for this.
And Silvio actually
took a sabbatical
leave to create a cryptocurrency
and a company around Algorand.
And I'm not sort of
marketing for him,
but I'm just commenting,
there's this debate.
Can you solve, basically,
what Satoshi Nakamoto wanted--
decentralization in a scalable
way and have it be secure?
So how does one
assess use cases?
Because this class
is ultimately about
sort of sorting through this.
Well, first he
asked the question,
is the project a project that
actually uses cryptocurrency,
or it services it?
And I give examples
of companies that
are in custody, in software, in
exchange operation, finances,
the crypto exchange.
Coinbase is both an
exchange and custody.
Fidelity, one of the world's
largest asset managers,
said, we'll take custody and
hold your cryptocurrencies.
So you could be on one
side of the divide and say,
we're going to be even like
a hardware company BitMain
and create the
hardware in this space.
Those are kind of used
classic strategy analysis
to think about those.
The sort of rougher
side of this is,
how do you consider what
are the strategic questions
about actually using
blockchain technology?
What are the value
creation propositions?
And I think it's
embedded in this--
is it worthwhile to have
decentralized computing
versus centralized computing?
Is there an area
that you think has
such high economic rents that
a decentralized competitor can
come in?
You could create the case that
if Uber and Lyft didn't exist
today, that Uber and
Lyft, you could say,
could be created on a
decentralized ledger system.
But nobody truly had control
of the ledger system,
and all the ride sharing could
be with drivers and users
using that decentralized app.
But then again, who would
have actually gone into city
after city, airport
after airport,
and should have done what
Uber and Lyft and others have
done to get into the system?
So I think the basic value
question is centralization
versus decentralization,
and secondly,
are you filling a gap in
the fiat currency system?
Fiat currencies
work pretty well.
Now, we're going to talk in
the next class about the pain
points.
And there are a lot of pain
points in the payment system
that take considerable
challenges
and costs to overcome.
Clearly, strategically what
are the competitors doing--
traditional competitors,
those using blockchain.
Why use append-only
logs, this invention
of this ledger system?
Why have multiple-party
consensus?
Multiple-party
consensus is a cost.
So if you're going to
use it for trade finance,
you're going to try to
solve something and trade
finance for instance, what is
it solving, what are the costs?
It can lower verification
and networking cost.
That's the core
of its economics.
But it comes with some cost.
There are also a series of
tactical considerations--
literally, what data
is going to be put in?
Who is the multiple
stakeholders?
What are the trade-offs?
And I think what we've
found by and large
is there are not that many
projects that have taken off.
I have here a little
bit deeper dive.
If you get so close to a project
that you think, all right,
now let's think about it--
I come back to this question
about multiple-party shared
ledgers.
In Bitcoin, the multiple-party
shared ledger has worked
in part because there
was a desire to have
a censorship-resistant token--
a token that could be global,
truly move around the globe,
at times away from what the
official sector might ban,
away from certain money
laundering anti-terrorism laws,
that's part of it--
but also that it was,
at least initially,
hard to track and trace.
It's actually gotten easier
to track and trace over time.
But really the
question is, if you're
going to think about using
blockchain technology,
what verification cost
are you really lowering,
and why have this multiple-party
distributed ledger?
A little bit like a
shared stock company
still has a lot
of centralization.
You have thousands of people
that control a shared stock
company, this invention
of several centuries ago,
but you still have
the management team
that controls it.
How do you deal with that here?
So, what have we found?
We found that the incumbents,
big finance, by and large,
have stayed over to the
left-hand side of this screen.
They've stayed towards
traditional databases.
They haven't gone to
the cryptocurrency sort
of side of this screen--
permissionless open protocols.
They're exploring a little
bit the middle, what's
called private blockchain,
"private blockchain" saying,
20 or 50 companies get together.
Maybe-- like in Australia,
there was much fanfare in 2016
into, actually, 2017,
there was much fanfare
that the Australian
Stock Exchange
would use a permissioned
blockchain technology to update
their central clearing.
Now, many people
would tell you by 2020
that what the
Australians have done
was inspired by
blockchain technology,
but it no longer looks
like blockchain technology.
It's a decentralized,
distributed database.
But what the Australian
regulator said is,
we need somebody
to control this.
We need a central controller--
the complete opposite
of what Satoshi Nakamoto
was talking about.
Nakamoto was saying
no central authority.
But the Australians
said, well this
is the central clearing,
sort of the plumbing,
the central plumbing, of
the Australian stock market.
No, we need somebody who
has kind of the overall--
plays the overall referee
role, so to speak.
So incumbents by and large are
using traditional databases.
They're exploring some of
these permissioned databases.
They're not really
off to the side.
Romain, any questions?
AUDIENCE: None so far.
We have 12 minutes left.
GARY GENSLER: All right.
So let me just say something
about central bank initiatives.
Central banks-- and we'll chat
about this a little bit more
when we do payments-- central
banks have taken note of this.
And they've thought both, can
I use the blockchain technology
for our payment systems--
because central banks
in most countries
control those payment systems--
or can we actually create
a digital currency?
At first, I mean,
Bitcoin was not
really on the radar
of central bankers.
By 2018, it became on the
radar because the market had
taken off and it was,
for a brief moment,
worth almost $1 trillion.
It's back down to $200 billion,
now but they took note.
And in some countries
like Sweden,
they really said, maybe we
should be doing something here.
We should be creating a crypto
equivalent, a digital currency.
And one of the readings
was a Bank of International
Settlement reading, which
showed three different ways
that a central bank could
do a digital currency.
And this is just
for your reference
to remind you that it
was in the reading.
But going back to these
projects a little bit,
some of the projects
are just papers.
Ecuador tried to do
a project, actually--
a dollar-denominated
cryptocurrency.
And it failed because nobody
in Ecuador wanted to use it.
Ecuador was already dollarized.
But the one to watch
most closely, China,
which might be a hybrid--
and I'll go back to the chart
in a second--
China has announced they're
doing a digital currency
electronic payment.
It will be fully backed
by the central bank.
It will be fully a
renminbi or digital block.
And in a sense, it may be as
much a reaction to Bitcoin
as it's a reaction
to Alipay and WeChat
Pay being dominant in the
retail payment system in China.
And it's also a
reaction to Facebook
that was starting something
called the Libra project.
So this, again,
is a central tenet
where I am, where I think of
this as that the central banks
are reacting in part because
big tech has been reacting
and startups are there.
And they're saying, maybe
we can do something better.
The opportunities that they
see, the opportunities is
that they say,
well, maybe we can
stay in the means of payment.
We can promote
greater competition,
and we can address
some pain points.
But on the other side,
they're really worried.
They're deeply
worried that if they
offer the public a digital
representation of central bank
money, that they
might disintermediate
the commercial banks.
The central strategic
question for central banks
is, can we offer the public
a digital representation
of that which is paper?
So I've covered central bank
digital currencies too quickly.
I'm going to come back
to it when we talk
about payment systems as well.
But Romain, we only
have a few minutes
so I'm going to take questions.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, we have
a question from Victor.
AUDIENCE: Hi, professor.
I want to come back to this
point about handling databases
through a private
blockchain network,
because I didn't fully
understand how it would work.
Could you give me some
more guidance on it?
GARY GENSLER: So Satoshi
Nakamoto's concept
is that you could have
hundreds or thousands of folks'
computers sharing a
database, and it's
an open database, and
that that database can
secure the ledger through this
concept of a log structure--
block of data,
block of data, block
of data with cryptography.
The commercial banks
and the financial firms
said, we're not comfortable of
having hundreds or thousands
of people share a database.
In fact, we can't.
Under various guidelines of
privacy, of data protection,
we can't have hundreds of
people share that database.
But they're looking
at, maybe we can
have a shared form
of cooperation,
or what somebody might
call coopetition.
We'll cooperate around the
trade finance platform,
and then we'll
compete on top of it
for the provision of lines of
credit, and trade financing,
and so on.
So they've come
together and said,
maybe we can have a
shared closed system
amongst 20 banks, 16 banks,
30 banks, and the like.
And so there's five
or six big consortiums
trying to put together a trade
finance private shared ledger.
Now, once you have
that, once you say,
it's only these 18
firms will share it--
this form of cooperating
on a shared database
but competing on top of it,
that form of coopetition--
you don't necessarily
need a token.
So there's no cryptocurrency,
it's just a shared blockchain
technology database.
Some call it a Digital
Ledger Technology, DTP,
to contrast it with
cryptocurrencies.
I'm a little bit looser in
the vocabulary, admittedly.
But that's how-- that's the
conceptual framework for it,
if that helps.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, thank you.
GARY GENSLER: Let
me just say a couple
of ground truths in close.
I really do think--
and I don't know which
side to end up on,
Devin or Camilo's side,
in terms of, is it money?
But I think Nakamoto
solved the payment riddle--
avoiding double spending.
It's lasted 12 years.
Whether you like it, whether
you love it, hate it, two is--
I'm sorry, Hassan--
I'm kind of--
money is but a social
and economic construct.
I'm deeply with
Plato on that one.
But I respect those
that believe otherwise.
I mean, there's a
good debate that's
gone on a couple
of thousand years.
We already live in an
age of digital money.
And in fact, the corona
crisis will accelerate that.
We will still have
physical paper money,
but we'll use it less
and less in transaction.
And physical paper money is more
and more just a store of value.
We're not using
physical paper money
much as a medium of
exchange right now.
Append-only logs and
multi-party consensus
actually does provide
an alternative,
but it doesn't mean it's
everybody's alternative.
It can address
verification costs,
but it doesn't make sense to
adopt it unless there's really
some viability and a value
proposition of that shared
ledger system.
We didn't talk much about it,
but I will say one ground truth
is that the crypto markets--
that $200 billion market--
it's ripe with scams and frauds.
It just is.
And so what's happened by
2020 is cryptocurrencies
have evolved to be a speculative
asset class, generally
not that correlated
with equities and bonds.
And I'll give you one statistic.
The worldwide stock
of gold, that gold
that could be in four
Olympic-sized pools,
collectively is worth
$9 or $10 trillion,
roughly, collectively.
So some people would say a
speculative store of value
that's only worth 2%
of that, $200 billion,
might be worthwhile in a
big portfolio of a family
office or a hedge fund.
The ICO boom and bust
raised about $30 billion.
Not much is being
raised there now,
but it's worthwhile
to take note of.
Most of this is
lightly regulated,
and so retail investors are
not getting much protection.
I think that's unfortunate.
But I still come back
to the last point.
I think it's been a
catalyst for change.
I think it might be one of
these technologies we look back
in decades and say, it was a
remarkable catalyst for change
for central bankers,
and to think through
whether it's trade finance
or other areas in finance,
was their way to
form some cooperation
and compete on top of
it-- so coopetition?
But just like we didn't
know that the internet
and geolocation devices would
lead to disruption in rides--
you know, Uber and Lyft, we
couldn't predict in the 1990s
that the taxicab
business in New York
was going to be
completely disrupted.
We don't know what blockchain
technology and cryptocurrencies
will disrupt later in the
2020s or in the 2030s.
So that's kind of my wrap on it.
You can sort of
get a sense of why
I'm not going to say I'm
a maximalist in this area.
But I'm also not all
the way a minimalist.
The minimalist would say, no,
none of these ground truths
matter.
I think it's a really important
technology, if nothing else,
because it's been a
remarkable catalyst for change
on how central banks and others
think about payment systems,
which we'll take up in our next